hey welcome to the monitor the 2013
edition of the monitor we are back off
of our hiatus during which you saw a
bunch of pre-taped episodes but it's
time to talk about what's happening now
not a lot so what we're going to do is
we're going to concentrate on TV because
as you know TV is my best friend I'm
just kidding Chewbacca's my best friend
but ton of shows starting up over the
coming week so I want to highlight three
networks that have some things going on
we're going to start out with comedy
central this coming Wednesday starts a
new block with the return of workaholics
which is what its fourth season now I
have loved this show from jump it is of
course the tale of three best friends
from college who now live together at
work as telemarketers and basically
drink and screw up their way to comedy
gold if you have not seen this it's on
every kind of streaming outlet you can
imagine so do a little catch up on that
and get ready for season 4 starting but
before workaholics on Wednesday nights
we are looking at the Kroll show what
does Kroll show well it's Nick Kroll you
might know Nick Kroll from his role as
Rodney Ruxin on FX show the league he's
also been a stand-up for a very long
time and he's popped up in probably
every comedy group and show you can
think of he also has the dubious
distinction of playing one of the
cavemen on that old ABC caveman suit
come member when they licensed the
caveman characters from geico yeah he
was on that but anyway we're going to
forgive him for that he's a very very
funny guy and he's got his solo sketch
show that starting up he's bringing in a
ton of guest stars at least in the in
the premiere episode I saw ed Helms I
saw Adam pally who is on happy endings
of course he plays max a bunch of
recognizable faces also the young woman
who was the love interest in 21 Jump
Street I don't even remember her name
and I apologize for that she's very good
there's some and Jenny slate who's been
everywhere she was on girl she was an
old SNL alum point is nick kroll has a
lot of funny friends and he's bringing
them all along for the ride it is a
middling to good premiere episode but I
have high hopes for this one so I
recommend you check that out and of
course I cosine workaholics with all the
might my tiny frame can
stir but that is it for Comedy Central
let's talk about a different network so
TBS as we all know TBS is known for
hilarious comedy no it's not but but I'm
going to give him the chance because
they rescued from the garbage heap of
cancellation one of my favorite unsung
heroes of sitcom land over the past
couple of years and that is cougar town
which ran for three seasons on ABC
you're probably watching this right now
in your thinking cougar town seriously
seriously it was created and run by Bill
Lawrence who brought scrubs to
prominence and if you were at all a fan
of scrubs absurdist take on an ensemble
comedy cougar town's going to be up your
alley I know it doesn't seem like it and
they're very aware of what people think
about them based on their name every
title sequence has a different joke not
on life Bart Simpson writing on the
chalkboard but this one is a different
joke about seriously we called ourselves
cougar town and we're not about Cougars
at all anyway it is about a group of
friends in their 30s and 40s great cast
courteney cox busy philipps a bunch of
people who you will recognize even if
you might not know their names and after
three seasons they developed a fantastic
chemistry ton of laughs out loud moments
really really good show and it is back
on TBS for its four season so hopefully
this is not going to be like when
Diff'rent Strokes move to ABC or when
scrubs move to ABC because someone's
something is going from ABC somewhere
else so I'm hoping that there's going to
be an uptick in quality but anyway that
is on Tuesday night so that is something
to look forward to that's cougar town
let's talk about adult swim adult swim
of course manufacturer of all things 15
minutes long they've had somewhat uneven
quality in my esteem over the past few
years but one of the bright spots has
been Children's Hospital which is Rob
Corddry and david wain and a bunch of
other kind of comedy heavyweights take
on the medical drama if you watch
Children's Hospital and I hope that you
do you might be familiar with a news
show set within that universe called
newsreaders and newsreaders I don't know
why keep saying it like that newsreaders
has gotten a spin-off it is its own show
starting Wednesday night at midnight or
thursday morning at midnight
hang on how much of a temporal stickler
you are it is they the same comedy DNA
the same pedigree as the team behind
Children's Hospital and it's writing
staff is crazy town really really strong
comedy writers in this one and there's
just a lot to look forward to it is it
takes the hospital drama and it turns it
into the drama of running an
investigative news show with the deadpan
anchor and the ridiculous every that
happens off camera and all the politics
and things a lot to look forward to
their so might be a DVR unless you are
young enough that you can stay up that
late and still get up as early as the
rest of us humans do how old have I
gotten all of a sudden I'm hitching an
onion to my belt if I'm complaining
about staying up until midnight I'm
getting too old for the I'm exactly the
right age for the anyway that's it for
the first week in january we will be
back next week when there's more
offerings on the table it's not just
going to be TV thought there's going to
be TV too because as I told you TV is my
second best friend behind jewbacca
anyway we will see you next week but
until then inspirational catchphrase
here